We are beginning a lesson on network security.
let's first talk about why we need network security
in the first place. The Internet is actually subject
to a wide variety of attacks on various parts
of the infrastructure. One part of the infrastructure
that can be attacked is routing. So the internet's
routing protocol, the border gateway protocol, is notorious for
being susceptible to different kinds of attacks. For example,
on April 8, 2010, China advertised about
50,000 blocks of IP addresses from 170 different
countries. The event lasted for about 20 minutes.
In this particular case, the hijack appears to
have been accidental. Because the prefixes were long
enough such that they didn't disrupt existing routes.
But the fact that the route advertisements were
allowed to leak in the first place highlights
the vulnerability of the border gateway protocol.
Effectively, the border gateway protocol. Essentially allows
any AS to advertise an IP prefix to a neighboring AS, and that AS will
typically just believe that route advertisement and
advertise it to the rest of the
internet. These events that occur where an
AS advertises a prefix that it does not
own are called route highjacks. And they tend to occur more often than one might
expect. In addition to the event on April 8, 2010, another event in
2008 occurred where Pakistan hijacked the YouTube
prefixes, potentially as a botched attempt to
block Youtube in the country following a
government order. Unfortunately, the event resulted in disruption
of connectivity to YouTube for people all around the world. In January of
2006, ConEdison accidentally hijacked a lot of
transit networks, including level three Unet and
several other large ISPs disrupting connectivity
to many customers. And on April 25th
in 1995, one of the more famous route hijack incidents was the AS7007 incident,
where AS7007 advertised all of the IP prefixes on the entire internet. As
originating in its own AS, resulting in
disruption of connectivity to huge fractions of
the Internet. So we've surveyed some famous or, shall we say, notorious attacks
on Internet routing, but another part of
the infrastructure that's vulnerable Is naming or
the DNS. One very popular and effective means of mounting an attack on the
naming system is through something called reflection.
DNS reflection is a way of generating
very large amounts of traffic targeted at
a victim. In an attack called Distributed
Denial of Service, or DDos attack. Another
type of attack on the naming system is
Phishing, whereby an attacker exploits the domain
name system in an attempt to trick a
user into revealing personal information, such as passwords
on a rogue website. In general, denial of
service attacks are extremely common and can be
mounted in a variety of different ways. DNS
reflection is just one way that distributed denial
of service attacks are mounted. We'll explore some
others later on in this lesson. It's worth asking why
the internet is so vulnerable to different kinds of attacks.